the road to her son is littered with
signs of battle but inside the capital
they are still celebrating the Russian
withdrawal
and on Monday they were joined by
President Vladimir zielinski
[Music]
yep and of course it's
exhibited by this long way difficult way
because
this this war to the best heroes of our
country he received a hero's welcome
president zielinski came out to address
the residence of Carson his nation and
the world to show that Ukraine has been
Victorious here in the South and also to
show that he is a fearless leader
present here within artillery range of
Russian forces who are just across the
danipro river the arrival of Ukrainian
soldiers brought relief Jubilation and
admiration I want the whole world to
understand that the most essential thing
for any human being is freedom it's hard
to tell how I feel because today I want
to cry from happiness we've been waiting
for this day for a long time we are with
Ukraine with Ukraine in heart
president zielinski has accused Russian
forces of Human Rights abuses vital
infrastructure has been destroyed
there's no electricity or water mobile
communication hubs have been set up to
allow people to communicate with loved
ones
I personally know many girls who were
molested by the Russian military the
hardest thing for me was when my friends
were taken from their homes and Captain
basements or taken to temporarily
occupied Crimea
when you know what freedom is then you
know what oppression is and when you
meet your liberators I want to cry it's
unbelievable
the posters proclaiming Russia was here
forever still stand in some places but
it's the Ukrainian flag that flies here
now the Russians are not far away and
this place is still within Striking
Distance and they remind us of that as
we leave the city Assad baig Al Jazeera
her son